Депутатом став, а ось хороші манери так і не опанував.
«Слуга народу» Максим Бужанський прославився на всю Україну
своїм сексистським висловлюванням в бік журналістки.
А це рік тому у Верховній Раді Ірина Геращенко
відповідає на нецензурні висловлювання депутата Сергій Власенка.
Я не подстилка, ви подстилка, подстилка Путіна.
Таких прикладів чимало. З вуст народних депутатів,
які мали би бути взірцями політкоректності, за вісім скликань
злетіло немало сексистських висловлювань,
які лише підігрівали гендерні стереотипи.
Тепер у новій Верховній Раді рекордна кількість жінок -87 депутаток.
Це понад 20 відсотків.
Тож, і сподівання, що сексизму в українській політиці поменшає, вищі.
Марія Іонова з "Європейської солідарності", Марина Бардіна зі "Слуги народу"
та Інна Совсун з "Голос" є експертками з гендеру у своїх партіях.
Для кожної з них проблема сексизму також близька.
Звичайно, її взяли на посаду, бо вона коханка міністра.
Я хочу подивитись в очі кожній людині, яка таке сказала.
Відносно зовнішності коментарі..
Якщо жінка-депутатка презентує законопроект,
то це апріорі вже поганий законопроект,
не професійний, не досконалий.
Марина Бардіна від "Слуги народу" ще не отримала посвідчення депутата,
а вже вимушена реагувати на актуальний випад
її однопартійця Максима Бужанського на адресу журналістки.
Вона вважає, що слід запровадити санкційний механізм.
Я думаю, що це має бути інституційний механізм,
прописаний регламентним комітетом.
Має бути прописано, що таке сексизм, якщо ми говоримо про нього.
Ми не маємо карати невідвідуванням засідань,
бо так ми караємо всю Україну, а особистими бонусами, зарплатою.
27-річна Марина Бардіна ще зі студентських лав
цікавилася жіночими рухами та жінками у політиці.
У Верховній Раді вона увійде в міжфракційне об'єднання
"Рівні можливості", яке існує вже третє скликання.
Мета союзу депутаток різних партій - поліпшувати становище жінок
у суспільстві та забезпечувати гендерну рівність.
Саме завдяки діяльності об‘єднання депутаток
в Україні скасували список з 450 заборонених для жінок професій.
Ті тепер можуть, приміром, офіційно працювати
водійками великогабаритних машин, як-от пожежної.
Керувати літаками, поїздами метро.
Займається об’єднання і протидією сексизму у Верховній Раді.
41- річна Марія Іонова від партії "Європейська солідарність",
яка була також депутаткою минулої Ради, згадує,
що випадки неповаги до жінок у парламенті трапляються регулярно.
Останній кричущий випадок був з Вікторією Пташник,
коли вона доповідала про законопроектв комітеті
правоохоронної діяльності, де немає жодної жінки,
і як з неповагою звертався до неї інший депутат.
Казав, що не будуть тут жінки, не вистачало, щоб тут керували...
Депутатки досягли успіхів і в питанні політичної участі жінок.
Зокрема лобіювали зміни у виборчому кодексі,
за яким у кожній п'ятірці партійного виборчого списку
мають бути як чоловіки, так і жінки.
Працювали над програмами заохочення жінок займатися підприємництвом.
Ми побачили це на прикладі Донбасу, для внутрішньо-переміщених осіб,
як тільки якесь міні-кредитування, як жінки
швидко налагоджують своє мале підприємництво.
Щоправда, далеко не все вдалося.
Наприклад, так і не ратифікували Стамбульську конвенцію
з протидії домашнього насильства над жінками.
Досі немає правового визначення таких понять, як "сексизм"
і "образи, базовані на сексистських уявленнях".
Це має негайно зробити нова Верховна Рада,
переконана 35-річна Інна Совсун від партії "Голос".
Аби подолати дискримінацію у суспільстві,
парламенту слід присвятити увагу підтримці родинам з дітьми.
Наприклад, дати можливість працювати за гнучким
робочим графіком на державних підприємствах.
Якщо дитячий садочок працює до п’ятої, то це
означає, що хтось з батьків має йти з роботи опів на п’яту.
Вочевидь, що це впливає на виконання завдань,
на ставлення до тебе колег, та кар’єрні перспективи.
Роль парламенту - не просто врегулювання  на рівні законів
тих чи інших проблем, це в тому числі підняття
суспільних дискусій з приводу певних проблем.
Такі, на перший погляд, буденні питання релеватні
щонайменше для 53% українських виборців.
Саме така частка жінок у суспільстві.
Те, що у новій Верховній Раді більше жінок-депутаток,
дає шанс, що жіночий голос у Раді стане гучнішим.